hi everyone this is jeremy xi from the
khan academy
thanks for taking time out of the first
week of back to school or the third week
depending on where you are
wherever you're coming from we're super
excited to have you with us this
afternoon or this evening
and we're extremely lucky to have our
chief learning officer
kristin joining us to share with you
some really powerful strategies for
motivating your students
especially during this challenging
moment now because christian is all
about motivation
and what the research shows to be best
practices she wants to make this session
highly interactive as well
so please join us in the chat room at
tlk.io
con and i'll put that in the chat in a
second and you can chat directly with
kristin with me
and with your fellow educators across
the country chris will be asking some
questions
and she'll take some questions for you
at the end of the session as well
so that being said thank you again for
joining tonight i'm going to pass it
over to kristin
to share with you seven awesome tips
great thanks jeremy and i will echo
jeremy's thanks to you
for taking some time out of your busy
schedule to uh
to chat with us today and i hope that
you find
the the things that i have to share
helpful um and as jeremy said
please do also chat with each other
because i know we all learn from each
other
and i'd love to to hear your ideas as
well in the chat
so i'm going to start off by asking all
of you to think about
the the last thing you decided to learn
like a new thing a new skill and
something new you decided to try to pick
up
and think about why you decided to try
to learn that
and if you don't mind sharing you can
head over to that chat and just tell us
what it was
and maybe in a couple of words why you
decided to
take on that new learning challenge
and while you're doing that i'll tell
the little story of
what i've recently decided to learn so i
decided to
try to learn origami because i feel like
i have
terrible spatial skills like i can
follow the instructions like fold here
fold here i don't really understand how
it all comes together
in the end to make a bird or a frog
um so thinking about so i said all right
here's the thing that i want to learn
so let's see we've got some life drawing
online some balloon animals
uh tablets on uh how to use the tablet
to draw on your computer
that sounds like a good applicable skill
um
yoga that's a good one
siphoning water out of the pool
so cool looks like we have some good
things that people were learning
part of the reason i wanted to tell the
story of what i'm learning
is also because as we think about what
it is that motivates you
to learn we're going to come back to
these ideas
but i also had an interesting reaction
from my mom when i told her what i was
going to learn
and she said oh i would never try to
learn origami i would be terrible at
that
and it turns out that that reaction of
wanting to try something
that you think you might be good at and
not wanting to try things that you
don't think you're going to be good at
is one of the founding principles of
motivation
and over lots and lots of motivation
research
we can kind of boil down motivation into
some pretty simple equations
basically that motivation is
whether you expect you can be successful
at something and how much you value the
task
and in in education research jargon they
call this expectancy value theory
but really it just says we like to do
things when we think we're going to be
successful at them and there's some
value to doing them
and so as i go through the the tips that
we're going to talk about
they each kind of come back to this and
so as you're thinking about your
classrooms
as you're thinking about different ways
to motivate students you can think just
about these two simple things
how can i help students expect that they
will be able to do this
that if they try this they can be
successful at it
and how do you increase the value of the
task for them
and so those are those are the real
pieces that we
can kind of come back to for each of
these things that i that i'm going to
talk about
so the first one and the first idea is
to set goals together and monitor
progress
because you know what it turns out
nothing makes you feel like you'll be
successful in the future
like having been successful in the past
and a good way
to really mark whether you're successful
is by meeting a goal
so there's a success piece in here but
one of the reasons that goals can be
so powerful is because there's also a
value piece
and that comes in the setting goals
together so if the student has some
input into what the goal
is that actually increases the value of
the task it increases their buy-in to
the task
as well so it brings success and value
so that's pretty powerful in that
motivation
equation piece of things so thinking
about
setting goals is important it's
important to think about the
how big those goals are it turns out
even
for adults long-term goals
are pretty difficult to keep at to
maintain all of that work towards them
we want to set
short-term goals and they can build
towards a long-term goal
but even for our high schoolers we want
you know a specific goal probably not to
be longer than a week
in terms of what they're going to do and
we don't want to have too many of them
so we want to really boil down to the
the key things that we want to focus on
what are those together
and then a couple pieces one is we want
to think about how are we going to see
if we're on track
so how are we going to monitor our
progress whether that's each day
or a couple times during the day how are
we gonna know if if we're on track to
meet our goal
and the the third thing to think about
with goals is to
give people a plan when they get stuck
so
the first time you get stuck and you
don't and you're not able to think about
you know i seem like i'm off track on my
goal
how do you get yourself back on track
and actually talking about a plan for
what to do when you're stuck
particularly when we're talking about
distance learning and the students
potentially
on their own trying to work through some
problems what should they do when they
get stuck
so setting goals together and monitoring
progress
that's a a good piece so when you think
about that thing you just
learned think about what your goal might
be i know my goal
in the origami is to be able to make one
of those frogs that you can
hit the back of and it jumps uh we'll
see if i get there
but uh that's what i'm that's what i'm
currently working on for this week's
goal
so setting goals monitoring progress and
somewhat related to that
is then celebrating success so this idea
of hey you did it that's great
getting that feeling of accomplishment
is really important
but the other thing that this helps us
do is reflect and it can give us a
moment to stop and say
that was awesome great and also
are there things that what did what did
you do tell me where did you start and
where are you now
and get them to see their own growth
that's really motivating to see
yeah i did actually improve on that i
did get better
and then you can also ask questions like
what helped you get there
what was good and you can reflect on
what didn't go so well what would be
even better if
next time you did this thing so building
in a little bit of time
to reflect pays dividends down the road
in terms of helping students feel like
they have the tools
to grow and progress on their own and
build up their own
sense of ownership over what they have
but again comes back to feeling
successful and feeling like they can
be successful at what they're doing so
that's the second piece
the the third piece is thinking about
working collaboratively
so people in general even those of us
who are introverts
still like to have a feeling of
belongingness and so if we can work
together
on something we can work and each
contribute something and feeling like
i'm contributing to a piece of this
that can actually raise the value of a
task because we're working together on
it
i know in a lot of motivation um
language it's tempting to think about
things like uh leaderboards and we can
create a leaderboard and kids will be
motivated to get to the top of the
leaderboard
it turns out research tells us that that
those competitive
kinds of situations aren't great for the
kids who are
often at the the lower end of the
achievements spectrum
so to be kind of coming in you know in
the in the bottom half
over and over and over again that does a
lot more to
kind of crush students spirit than it
does to actually
motivate them to do better so and as
you're thinking about how to set up
group activities think about how you can
do that to encourage peer interaction
and
everyone having a contribution to make
towards a class goal
as opposed to thinking about individual
competition
between different members of the class
and where that works
and again this raises the value of the
task because you're thinking
i can move and i can i can
collaboratively
get to those spaces all right
fourth tip emphasize
effort leads to success so
this is a big piece again about thinking
whether you can be successful or not
and there's a lot of talk about um
thinking about how do we
you know growth mindset has kind of
become a buzzword
but it's based on some sound research
that says
that a lot of students don't believe
that if they work harder they can be
successful
and having them think about how that
happens isn't just about
oh just tell them they can be successful
keep working good effort
not going to work by itself but what
they have found is actually
teaching students a little bit about how
your brain works
and how practice actually does
change how your brain functions can
along with those kinds of messages help
students believe
that hard work does lead to success
and if you're looking for a little bit
of that um
a little bit of that information i'm
going to give a a little bit of a
plug here because there's actually on
khan academy
a course called growth mindset and
there's videos on there for elementary
school students and high school students
and i'm going to play a little snippet
of a video
that gets with this idea of how does
your brain actually grow
as you're learning new things so this is
just a quick minute of that
of that video when you struggle your
neurons are struggling too and that's
important because when neurons struggle
they lean on each other
they make connections they start to form
this densely connected network inside
your brain
allowing little jolts of electricity to
pass down them more and more efficiently
that's thinking faster that's your brain
getting
smarter that's your brain muscle getting
swole kid
so the next time you say to yourself i
can't do this
i'm just too dense remember that brain
density is your friend
in fact the denser you are the more
connections between nelly and her neuron
pals that you've got inside your brain
the stronger and more powerful your
thinking parts become
the more you work through your
frustrations with the right learning
strategies
the more your neurons get more used to
working together the closer you are
to being that much smarter
all right i'm going to switch back to
our presentation here
so what you saw there is that idea of
helping students understand that it is
the case that as you practice
as you learn more your brain is actually
changing
and that's what then is going to help
you answer all those questions and be
able to solve those problems
so it's a big piece that we can think
about again not just kind of
praising effort but helping students
understand how
it really does lead to them
understanding and being able to do more
things
so that's that's a step for tip four
there
let me go to number five so
relationships
so i talked a little bit about kind of
peer relationships
but the other thing that uh is really
important is of course your
relationships with students and i'm sure
i'm not telling any of you anything new
but in this distance learning world that
can be really difficult to form
so think about how at the beginning of
this school year
you usually start building relationships
with your students and
if you're in the in the chat room and
want to type
a couple things that you've tried this
year if you are a distance
or you have some remote learning how
you're trying to build relationships
this year within a distance environment
with your students
so a couple of things we can do is is
one is
definitely think about how you are
coming to know your students as people
like what are their what are they
interested in what are the things that
they think about what are the things
they worry about
what are the things that make them happy
um kind of
all of those pieces are important as we
start to
understand who our students are and as
students
build relationships with you they
actually
will be more willing to do the things
you're asking because you're asking and
they value
their relationship with you so that
relationship building pays off
both in terms of uh you know just having
good relationships with your students
but also in terms of motivation
um and i see that this idea uh that
julia posted about being your genuine
self and
that is part of relationship building is
sharing a little bit of yourself too
being your quirky self or sharing a
little bit that's different
and all of that is important to make it
a two-way street in the relationship of
what you're doing
um so i want to emphasize that that is
so important
um think about if there's ways when
you're doing a synchronous call that you
don't just jump right into the content
but you have some time where you're
getting to know your students and
they're getting to know each other to
help build those together
and so lots of things like i see morning
check-ins
and all of those good ideas for helping
to
to build those up so that is number five
build relationships
number six establish relevance so i know
this is like the
one of the top 10 most hated questions
when am i ever going to use this
but it turns out that the value of the
task
is really related to how relevant it is
to a student
and it doesn't mean that yes you're
going to use this specific
pythagorean theorem in our future in
your life
but think broadly about what students
goals are
and think about how the things you're
learning relate to
maybe it's outside interests maybe it's
career goals
maybe it's just related to something
else they want to learn how to do
any way that you can make the things
that they're learning relevant
to the real world and applicable in the
real world
increases that value of the task to
students
so really important to think about how
they can connect
what they're learning to their lives so
that's an important piece and
and do some thinking about it and be
explicit about it when you're
starting a lesson or you're thinking
about here's the objectives
and here's how i make those objectives
seem like they're going to be relevant
to
what um what my students care about so
that is number
six and number seven
let's talk about rewards so rewards are
tricky
to get right but they can work and um
and i know as an adult i reward myself
when i do things when i have to do a
long writing task i break it up
and give myself you know a little piece
of chocolate
after i finish a little bit um lots of
folks do with
you know with all kinds of exercise apps
do things where they
reward themselves people who do you know
personal finance
rewards after you save a certain amount
of money all those things work for a
reason
we do like getting them the key is
there's a couple of
things in in terms of the research about
how to use rewards wisely
so the first is you want to
be careful because students that are
already doing something because it's
really interesting to them
if you start rewarding them too much for
it they start to think oh i'm just doing
this for the reward instead of doing it
because it's interesting to them
so we don't want to like kill that
intrinsic internal motivation
by giving external rewards but there's
good ways
to use rewards that actually don't do
that so the first is if you have
students that
you know aren't that interested internal
rewards can be a good way to get someone
started
uh our external rewards can be a good
way to get someone started on something
so that then they can experience that
feeling of success
they can do all of those things that
then kind of move them towards more
internal rewards
the other things that are helpful with
rewards is to sometimes make them
surprising
like here's a little piece of joy for
doing the thing that you just did
um so if they're not on a fixed
schedule it's more likely that they'll
be effective something that's surprising
and different for them
and the third piece is don't make them
big they can be little things
also think about you know praise the
reward
think about small little things that
someone you know likes to do
and it goes back to this relationships
piece about thinking about
if you know your students you know that
what they care about
you can think about a little bit more
about what what will be rewarding to
them and what kinds of things are
rewards but again not big things
little pieces do it sometimes
unexpectedly and think about how we can
build those
uh that together so that we start with
some of these
external rewards to build momentum
towards more internal intrinsic feelings
of
reinforcement for doing what we want
them to do so
all of the all said and done here
are the the seven things we just talked
about so
setting goals and monitoring progress
celebrating success working
collaboratively
emphasizing effort leads to success
building relationships
establishing relevance and using rewards
wisely
so with that let's open it up for
questions
and thoughts jeremy's got the uh the
chat and he's gonna feed me in
questions or comments or thoughts that
might be uh interesting to talk about
yeah thank you so much kristen you
definitely sparked a great conversation
in the chat room
if you want to join that those links are
in the chat
come over to tlk dot io con
um you can ask questions right there you
can ask questions and go to webinar
control panel
but you've got a rockstar researcher
and a motivation expert at your disposal
right here so any questions
big or small kristen is happy to take
them on
okay so we're gonna start with a
question from sage sage says kristen
we've got some kids who are very
hesitant to be on camera
which our administration is actually
requiring this year any good tips to
help encourage them
in this very frightening environment
so a couple things so first is
find out if you can try to get a little
bit to the
the root cause there what is it that
they're is making them hesitant what is
it that they're
not sure of so uh in some cases i've
heard about you know that the the issue
is
being nervous about showing their
background like if they
live someplace they're not real excited
to show where they live
and what that looks like um and think
about you know are there ways to
either you know set up a
towel against the wall set up use using
your shot depending what your software
allows some of the virtual backgrounds
so you know i think a piece of it is it
that they don't you know like how they
look is it they don't like the
background
depending on what that the root causes
is probably going to depend on how you
want to
address you know what the issue is and
try to
encourage them for do from doing it it's
probably
um i would suggest that it's probably
not great to
do a lot of commenting on people's
videos and backgrounds
unless they're doing something
explicitly fun that
to bring attention to it because that
probably starts to create
a comparison issue where you know oh
they have this really fun thing in the
background and i don't have that
those kinds of things so but with but as
with lots of things
if you can do anything to get at the the
root of what's kind of going on there or
maybe helpful to figure out how to then
think of a solution yeah it definitely
seems like spot on advice kristin
because it seems like
a lot of districts are trying to find
ways to keep sessions interactive
but also respect students privacy and
all that um and sage says that's super
relevant in
in their district so that's awesome um
another question
came in and it said any suggestions this
is from julia
what to do in the moment so like here
you are your third hour of zoom
the student is starting to hit a wall
how do you bring that extra oomph of
motivation right when you need it
yeah so i will suggest a little
pre-planning
um some of the things i know for those
of us that
um are uh on
zoom lots during the day i'm on zoom
calls you know
all the time um it helps just to stand
up
like stand up and shake and get the
wiggles out uh there's a lot
for you know just staring at that screen
is difficult
so i would definitely suggest that um
you know let's all take a break uh let's
everybody stand up you can even you know
lead a couple of those stretches do some
arm circles
do some toe touches you know get things
get things going and
just uh take a quick break and honestly
as we're talking about screens
the recommendations from the eye doctors
are that for every 20 minutes you're
staring at a screen
you take a 20 second break and look at
something 20 feet away so it's the 20 20
20 roll
so that can be helpful too just giving
your brain a chance to
to check out and then the the third
thing
that i will recommend is we actually at
again
khan academy and jeremy maybe you can
find the link to these and put them in
the chat
we actually have a little uh little
piece of a section of cards that we call
refresh
and the refresh cards are just the
simple little
questions that you can have students do
thanks jeremy's put those in the chat
um that just ask students questions like
uh
if 2020 were a food what would it be or
you know
draw a picture of yourself in some crazy
environment so all kinds of different
things
uh that can be just again a good break
for the brain
doing something else doing something a
little bit different
cool and um we had actually asked that
same question what would 2020 look like
in food form
one of our webinars a few weeks back and
i would say teachers were very creative
um some people said it looked like
haggis it looked like spoiled potato
salad
so definitely a good way to get teachers
and students alike
feeling motivated okay another quick
question comes in here from denise
and denise says one of the hardest
things with distance learning is
collaboration
you know i used to break my students up
into groups and have them work together
and that was awesome for building
connections and also accelerating
learning how do we do that in this
environment
so this is going to depend on software
and school policies because just
glancing over
at the chat i see denise saying her
school doesn't allow unsupervised google
meet
um so that makes things a lot more
difficult
um so id i'll give you the ideal answer
and then i'll do some other pieces so
lots of software like zoom actually has
breakout rooms and you can assign
students to groups of three or four
and have them they get together and you
can actually drop in
as the teacher to the different rooms uh
at various times and see how they're
doing
and where those are so that's kind of an
ideal situation
but again no lots of you are there's
issues with zoom there's issues with
district policies and there's issues
with
uh with how to make that work so that
um if you're thinking about where those
are if you don't have access to that
here's some other ideas
one is is there any uh
software where they're not looking at
each other and not uh
you know not using video but are
collaborating on a document so
google docs is an example of that where
um you know
they're actually in the document writing
and solving you know potentially writing
together
everyone's writing a section or you know
putting a section together and working
together on it and
they can talk to each other in the
potentially the chat
you know piece of the google docs to
coordinate back and forth of that work
so there's one
one thought of you know kind of how to
get people working together
on things um there's the idea of
having just a small group together with
you but that
puts huge demands on your time to be
able to do that but it might be
depending again on your district
policies instead of doing two hours of
the whole class
would it be worth breaking them into you
know five
groups and doing four sessions over that
two hours instead
again district policies i know
uh so think about what are the solutions
that you might be able to have to get
around
those kinds of things being able to give
all the students
a problem um again to work on together
uh in some you know google documents
something like that and then coming back
as a whole
and sharing the different solutions from
the different groups
all kinds of different pieces to think
about um
but it's going to depend a lot on what
software you have and
what kind of constraints you're in with
with what your district can do
if worse comes to worse think about your
whole group and your
you know uh you're trying to encourage
at least collaboration among peers uh
when you're all together in a whole
group setting
yeah so hard to do right now but it
looks like tammy and dusty and mary have
had some great ideas
nearpod padlet jamboard cammy so
definitely explore those
um larissa has a really interesting
question which is
kristin do you have any really practical
how-to tools to help kids set goals and
then monitor those on a weekly basis
i've always wanted to do this with my
kids but i've never found a practical
way to do it and it always seems so time
consuming like so much follow-up is
involved
how do i practically get this off the
ground
and i'm sorry i i missed the to help
kids do what
oh i'm sorry to actually help kids set
goals so going back to one of your goals
wow okay seems like a great idea theory
but how do you execute
yes so in thinking about goal setting
one of the simple things to do is to
and you can find these you know all over
the internet but just to create a little
template
that says what do you want to
accomplish in math this week uh
how will you do that it helps them think
about their plan
what will you do if you get stuck and
how will you know if you're on track
and like just kind of giving them a
simple
you know four questions that they can
answer that kind of gets at those
important things about goal setting
that they can work through and if you
can have an individual conversation with
one of them that's great
and think about what that's doing you
can
in that first setting suggest some goals
so hey we want to think about a reading
goal and we want it to
you know how much you're going to read
and what that looks like so
how what do you think we should do and
what that looks like so
all of those pieces i think could
potentially be you know
either collaborative you can provide a
little bit of guidance for each of those
questions
but a really simple template um is the
the best thing that i've seen and
there's lots of examples kind of around
the web of those kinds of
uh just easy goal setting templates
great so i think we're at the bottom of
the hour i know it's getting a little
late on the east coast especially during
those first few important weeks of
school but i want to thank you so much
kristen for sharing your expertise in
wisdom tonight
thank you awesome to also to all the
awesome educators out there across the
country
for joining and then sharing your own
expertise this has been a super
good demonstration of learning through
collaboration so
um wish you all tremendous success um
with the rest of the school year
and kristen as we end any final words of
wisdom any sort of um
things you want educators to be thinking
about as they head into a tough school
year
um i just want to first say thank you
again to all of you
and that you are probably each other's
best resource so
collaborate with each other and reach
out to each other and we're here to help
as we can
wonderful with that being said here's
wishing you all a great evening a great
start to the school year
and tremendous success on the road ahead
cheers all